do you have
a fear of bathing do
you prefer a mud pit to a shower
if you enjoy having your own brand of
smells you might wonder what if
you were the dirtiest man on earth
what kind of bacteria would your body
grow
would you become dehydrated
and would you have to live alone
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were the dirtiest man
on earth in
2014 amwa [ __ ] went on record with the
tehran times
claiming he hadn't cleaned himself in
nearly
60 years amwa refuses to bathe because
he believes it will cause disease
living on the outskirts of his iranian
village
he remains isolated from his neighbors
and family
so if you were to stop bathing
would you have to sleep outside too
living without a daily cleaning ritual
might keep your loved ones away but
you wouldn't be alone right now between
2 million and 10 million bacteria are
living
on your fingertips and elbows and
if you've never exposed these areas to
soap and water
there would be even more of these tiny
disease-ridden house guests
living on you according to a 2009 study
by the centers for disease control and
prevention
69 percent of men don't wash their hands
after using the bathroom oh
and eighty percent of illnesses caused
by germs
are spread by your hands it's even more
troubling when you consider that every
flush
can spray germs up to 1.8 meters
these microorganisms can live on your
body for up to
three hours and if you're not cleaning
your skin
germs aren't the only thing living on
you
you might develop fungal infections
around your nails that could
cause them to crack apart and break
bacteria
would build up in the folds of your skin
around your nails
giving you a staph infection since these
areas are going unwashed
this bacteria could lead to a fungal
infection
you could develop tinea creoris also
known as jock itch
or tineapedis athlete's foot
or maybe you would contract candida
an infection that spreads to your mouth
throat
gut and your groin and if you don't
treat it
it might enter the bloodstream and
spread to your organs
outside your body the dirt and grime
would be
building up on layers of dead skin
your skin would dehydrate causing it to
flake and itch
sebum the oil on your skin would build
up causing
acne across your face chest and back
your skin could harden and thicken to
fight the infection
developing into a condition called
hyperkeratosis
this dense protective layer would be
made of keratin
the same proteins found in your hair any
exposed skin would turn dark scaly and
rough
leading to a disorder called dermatitis
neglecta
this inflammatory skin condition is a
direct result
of your not bathing and
since you're not dealing with this
primary infection
it would lead to secondary infections
across your body
your immune system would be compromised
you would need a steady supply of
antibiotics to treat these illnesses
but most doctors only prescribe this
medication
for two weeks and since you're taking so
many antibiotics to fight off your
chronic infections
your body would build up a resistance to
the drugs
a 2013 study by the centers for disease
control and prevention found that
almost 2 million people in the united
states get an antibiotic resistant
infection
every year and at least 23
000 of those people die oh and another
noticeable sign of your decay
your matted hair not washing your hair
for weeks
may lead to it becoming thicker with
more volume but
with the bacteria building up from the
moisture on your scalp
after several days your hair might smell
like sour milk
your hands would show how infectious
your skin has become but
it's the part you don't see that's
getting worse
that part under your shirt in a 2012
study published in
plos one researchers found
2 368 species of bacteria
living inside people's belly buttons
and 1500 of those bacteria
may be new to science whether you're an
innie or an audi your dirty belly button
would become
an ecosystem that would rival the amazon
oh and we're assuming that if you're not
washing yourself
you're not washing your clothes either
every stain on the fabric would press
against your skin
this constant contact with the dirty
fibers would irritate your skin
leading to dermatitis the rash
would leave you red and flaky and
since you never bathed your sweat would
mix with your dead skin cells and dirt
soon your body odor would become
obnoxious
keeping everyone away from you so
you'd have plenty of time for yourself
you know according to the centers for
disease control and prevention
the average person showers for eight
minutes
so if you stopped showering you'd gain
an extra two days each year to do
whatever you wanted and with all that
time to yourself
you could check out the content on
curiositystream
the sponsors of this episode
curiositystream
offers thousands of documentaries
non-fiction titles and
exclusive content from some of the
world's best filmmakers
get unlimited access starting at just
2.99 a month
or 19.99 a year you could reflect on
your isolation with the documentary
mustang journey of transformation it's a
really cool exploration of one of the
last
buddhist sanctuaries tucked away in the
himalayas
or check out hidden japan learn about
the thousands of diverse
islands and habitats that might offer
you a new start
curiosity stream is available worldwide
so
as long as you have a signal you can
watch on your smartphone or
other streaming devices and for what if
viewers
you get the first 30 days completely
free when you sign up at
curiositystream what if
and use the promo code what if sign up
now and start your journey
into the unknown today but
your new hobbies should be the least of
your concerns
the way you stink you wouldn't be able
to hold a job unless it's
remote and don't count on keeping a
roommate
or a romantic partner with the
self-imposed
isolation and the preventable diseases
infecting your body
being the dirtiest man on earth wouldn't
just end your relationships
it might end your life and
if you stopped cleaning your body what
would happen to your
dental hygiene what if you stopped
brushing your teeth
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]